I wrote something for one of my
daughters and at this point one of my
daughter's was quite frankly not
treating my wife with the kind of
respect that my wife deserves you know
it was typical teenager stuff I roll the
eyes a flippin comment basically young
adolescent girl with young adolescent
attitude what you talked about earlier
no no one can tell me anything I know
everything and in her mind you know my
wife was just some lady that did the
laundry got the groceries and cooked
dinner and that's how she treated her
and so I wrote this for my daughter but
I wanted to read it for everyone you
know and I want to dedicate it not just
to my wife but to all the military wives
out there holding the line on the home
front so this is what I wrote to my
daughter
your mom I wanted you to know a little
bit about your mom your mom was a
champion horse rider
she rode cross-country races showjumping
and she did fox hunting she cared for
her horses every day
clean them train them and took care of
them she won many victories your mom
worked since she was little
starting in restaurants first peeling
potatoes than busing tables than
cleaning than waitressing to make money
your mom went to an extremely good
college her parents didn't pay for it
she worked through college as a waitress
to pay your own way when your mom got
done with college she took the money she
saved
and backpacked around the world she went
to Thailand Malaysia Hawaii Australia
New Zealand and a bunch of other places
while doing that she worked as a
waitress another odd job so she could
make money and pay her own way when your
mom got done traveling the economy was
bad and she couldn't find a job so she
went overseas and worked at an airline
as a flight attendant which is a hard
thankless job serving ungrateful
passengers on planes she didn't like it
but she did it when I met your mom for
the first time she was the most
beautiful girl I had ever seen and when
I talked to her she was the nicest
person I have ever met and she was funny
and sassy and sweet and I knew
immediately that I wanted to marry her
so your mom picked up everything and
left and came to be with me in America
she moved into a tiny one-bedroom
apartment with me she was wonderful she
was adventurous she surfed with me and
she trained jiu-jitsu with me every day
and worked out with me every day she got
her blue belt in jujitsu she worked as
an executive assistant in a real estate
office and got a real estate license we
went skiing and hiked mountains and
camped under the stars in the mountain
and we went dancing at night she was
amazing I got orders to move to Virginia
she instantly packed up everything we
had and quit her job and moved across
country when we got to Virginia she got
a tough job working for an insurance
company of course I was in a seal
platoon so I traveled all the time and
was gone all the time and she never
complained
one day she told me she was pregnant
that was you
she was so happy and then the day after
you were born I left on deployment for
seven months she did everything by
herself
I was gone she never complained and she
sent me a picture every day of you when
I got home from deployment
she was already back in shape and looked
amazing the Navy gave me orders back to
California without a word your mom
packed away all of our stuff quit her
job and we moved back to California I
worked and went to school I never got up
in the night to help take care of you it
was always your mom every time she
changed every diaper made every meal
tried every tear read every goodnight
book I worked went to school and trained
jiu-jitsu she never complained one
single time soon she told me she was
pregnant again that was your first
sister when your first sister came now
everything that your mom did for you she
had to do for your sister too every
diaper every meal every tear every
little book read I was working and going
to school and training she walked you
both and read to you and took you to
parks and play groups and dancing
lessons and swimming lessons and craft
fairs she did everything for you she
didn't get to surf anymore or do jujitsu
anymore or workout or hike with me
anymore she devoted all that time to you
her kids who she cherished she never
complained or whined or asked for
anything then she got pregnant again
this time it was your brother she kept
doing everything for you when she got
her morning sickness throwing up dizzy
and carrying around a baby in her belly
she didn't complain ever when she was in
the bath
SiC and throwing up she would apologize
to you and you said you and your sister
that you girls had to see her like that
then the war started I went back to the
SEAL Teams I went to Iraq for six months
I was working so much that I barely got
time to write your mom always wrote me
she never complained about anything she
did everything by herself everything I
was taking care of my seal platoon and
she took care of you three little kids
she cleaned everything made every meal
changed every diaper dried every tear
took you to lessons and parks and
doctors appointments and read to you
every night and major lunches and got
groceries she did this all by herself
no in-laws to help out no grandparents
around just her alone when I came home
things didn't get any better I just
started getting ready to go back to Iraq
again she didn't complain some guys had
to worry about their families their
wives would complain and cry and filed
for divorce and fight over the kids I
never worried about that at all
your mom took care of everything and
never made me have to worry about you
kids or her or anything else my last
deployment to Iraq I was gone almost
seven months I left your mom alone again
with you three kids some of my men were
wounded and killed your mom went to the
hospital to visit the wounded men and
went to the funerals of my friends your
mom knew at any time it could be me that
was wounded or killed but she never
complained she cried with the moms of my
friends
she gave support where she could but she
never asked me to stop or come home or
leave early or even be safe never she
never asked me to give anything to her
she knew I had men to take care of she
told me not to worry about her or all
you kids she only told me to do my best
at my job and take care of my friends on
the battlefield most seals get divorced
almost 90% there is too much pressure
and separation and distance and too many
challenges and many women can't take it
so they leave your mom never wavered she
never had an issue or a complaint no
matter what happened or when I came home
or when I left or what I did she
supported me always and she took care of
you kids every day every night every
moment every need you had was her
responsibility she never asked for
thanks or appreciation and when it was
her birthday or our anniversary she
would tell me not to get her anything
so we could save money when I got home
from my last deployment to Iraq
your mom got pregnant again that was
your youngest sister and she did it all
again morning sickness diapers sleepless
nights puke in the bed pee on the floor
chickenpox lice tears scrapes bumps
bruises teacher conferences school
lunches everything she never complained
about it I was still working
preparing men for war and traveling all
the time and she continued to take care
of you kids so I could do my job
your mom is stuck with me through hell
it has been hard
your mom has been married to this
hard-headed frogman for 17 years she's
been through multiple wartime
deployments she has helped me when I was
sick or injured and she has done the
same for you she has done it because she
is strong and determined and she loves
our family more than anything in the
world your mom is an incredible person
an amazing woman and I worship her she
is everything I ever wanted
so when you get the chance you should
tell your mom that you love her that you
know how much she has done for you and
for our family and that you appreciate
everything that she has done for us and
for you I hope you grow up and have some
of the same qualities that she possesses
strength honor intelligence dignity
selflessness respect determination and
kindness that's your mom and I hope you
realize how blessed you are ever
[Music]
and that's the note that I wrote to my
daughter and you know there's some
people that say a woman can do anything
that a man can do then I don't know if
that's true or not but I can tell you
this I don't know of too many men that
can do what my wife has done and what
thousands of other military wives have
done